I'm Jen Aniston my name is Adam Sandler
and we are spilling the E.T beans
[Music]
all right I'm ready okay
you're cute your hoodie I'm just
blocking things
[Laughter]
okay fans are so excited about it right
we can just put a green screen on your
face
I need to remember what happened last
time we were on a getaway yeah some
people died not a lot a lot of people
you'd think five people dines a lot fans
are so excited to see us together what
is the best part of being my on-screen
partner why am I your favorite
wow what Drew is so angry no you're the
best
Anderson you're why is it so much fun
with you is that the question uh no it's
it's what is the best part of being my
on-screen partner and why am I your
favorite I'll repeat it again
uh Well you certainly
certainly have a way about making life
fun on the set oh you're caring
you care about how I'm doing how what
why if I'm enjoying my life if I'm
healthy and you do things to make my
beard smell better
you you're uh you when you kiss when you
kiss me do the kissing scenes you wait
to go into the other room to scream what
the hell was that right and uh
that's it that's all I got for you okay
I had a burger all right sandal man and
a burger this movie is so fun uh-huh we
shot all over the world Hawaii Paris
what was the wildest thing that happened
to us when we weren't filming do you
want a cookie first
what is the craziest thing that happened
outside of the movie
it's so wild we didn't do very many Wild
Things what about uh that when the
elephant got loose from the uh when the
elephant got loose
diaper we lost it is not a problem and
you made me change it and I made you
change it yep that was probably the
wildest thing
we're back for our sequel of murder
mystery yes but what is one other movie
you would most want to do with stable up
well first of all I just noticed you
don't have your glasses on when you're
reading that's why it's fun to see you
struggle
I've never seen you like I know you
don't know where to put that
um I'd say uh would I do a sequel to
that that bahui Hollywood shakes the
clown chase the clown why don't you sit
back enjoy and watch the master Bobcat
Goldthwait by one of my first movies I
would do that again but I want to see
what happened to my guy I want to see
what happened to bobcat and uh yeah
Blake Clark okay well there you heard it
here that was this let's get it going
buddy
are taking on his second careers in this
if you were to leave the industry
tomorrow what will we find you doing uh
I wish I was a doctor huh I wish I knew
more about the human body I wish I could
fix things that were if someone was
aching that I so I think I'd go after
that okay could I get into med school I
don't think so
anything's possible you can do anything
you want I don't know yeah okay and I
don't know if I would honestly trust you
with my body part first thing I would do
is fix that finger of yours
my my fingers that I lost when I was 20
in a in a car door when I slapped it in
a Chevy Blazer I'd get you a better one
immediately if you're in med school you
get a cadaver I would take snap it right
off and give it to you
I asked you guys you ready you got it
I don't want to kill anybody
oh what some action-packed scenes here
Jen
what was all the training like for you
because I remember you going bananas
suspended an air in a dress yeah any
fight scene fails uh during production
No but somebody else in a fight scene
fail a guy hit me in the face you got
hit by it in the face by Mark Strong why
did he hit me I don't know he didn't
mean to was just he was you were too
close yeah he felt terrible smacked me
good anyway I didn't train for this it
would be just my normal you're always
training well that's just what my normal
she's always looking pretty strong you
can't mess with Anniston and it was just
it was a harness but still you had to
read you had to do a lot of stuff my
back would have given out very quickly
you don't work out I don't work the
lower back as much as you need to I
should be I tell them all the time I
tell them these things
I always say yes that I will yeah then
you don't I know but I do say yes you
gotta admit that okay that's just the
beginning that's the start we see a
lavish wedding in this movie we do
remember the Maharaja is getting married
yeah what was the most lavish Luxe event
you've ever been to
uh I would have to say your daughter's
apartment
I knew you were gonna say that that was
a big that was that was big to do pretty
huge that was a lot of people a lot of a
lot of food I didn't know where I was
like walking into Disneyland on crack
dude you know what the what was the
weird best part and the worst part which
part of the crowded crowded crowd lots
of people lots of children the elephant
showing up
love you sonny love you sonny
sorry about your phone
um that's your turn
we've been friends for decades yes uh I
was gonna say we've been friends for
decades what's to see if you never told
anyone just tell everyone right now
come on do it
you love cookies
take one bite I don't want to cook
my God yes oh that's an Unstoppable I
don't have a secret a secret I'm not
gonna tell you you don't have any
secrets I don't have any secrets you
keep that I'll keep it I don't care keep
it Precious Precious you want to go over
me I'm gonna go what is a question you
have always wanted to ask me
ask me
okay ask all right let me think uh why
inquiring
ET minds want to know
okay Bean Spiller all right the Rachel
oh God I know no one talks to you about
that
I want to just know when you first saw
it in the mirror for the first time did
you say this is it this is the one I
wanted this is this this is fantastic it
feels soft it looks beautiful I really
did enjoy it when it first happened I
was like that's really different from
what I yeah I've ever had before it was
a great one lasted for about six months
after six months did when did did you
say get it off I got I can't do the
Rachel anymore I just started growing it
out and it was too hard because I
couldn't do it on my own and I just
looked all right Rosanna really
[Applause]
no I think I'm done are we done with our
questions yeah yeah I feel we spilled
what are you gonna do with that are you
just gonna take us it
all right well I feel like we've spilled
something we've spilled a lot of beans
we spilled even more than that our heart
our soul gave our heart and soul out to
it and uh did it for E.T because et's
always been nice to us been there for us
forever and ever and ever literally
let's do it I know any good time totally
100 you you go
uh no no you're totally wrong David I'm
sorry I'm just being interviewed and you
know what I can't concentrate
what I have in there I don't know one
day you will make movie with me not my
words how many ET interviews do you
think you have done in your life that's
my last question
I have the answer I mean I almost want
to say you're the exact number
right here
4012.
[Music]